the position of a pixel on the screen
would be defined by two numbers it's a
2d thing but if you're making a 3d game
then you know the position of this
object is could have three numbers in
the world in the simulated world right
so three dimensions like how far along
is it this way how far along is it that
way and how far along is it that way
right and when you program a game you're
just always working with those three
numbers I was just curious what would it
be like if there were four numbers when
you one of those kids say were like as a
teenager would you make your own crappy
little games or um I didn't really have
access to something that would let me
program or something but I would
definitely like draw them on paper like
I would have like notebooks that were
basically the you know the manual for
the game I would make fake manuals but
there was no game there was no game but
the different people I was like the
description it was basically like a
design document but I didn't know that
that existed at the time it was just
like well I want to create a video game
and that's what I know how to make is a
you know a manual this is mega cray the
actual game I just had this image of
what the game was going to be and so I
just sat down and made it you don't just
sit at a computer and start typing do
you like do you draw a map or do you
like do you write things on paper or
storyboard a game or like how what's a
lot look like at this point start typing
I mean it's not a game that's designing
from the top down
right it's just I'm making this thing
and I'm gonna explore where it's gonna
need me and so at first I just typed the
things that I know and then it will give
me more stuff and then I'll react to
those and I make different things based
on that sounds like you're just sitting
at a computer typing into the void yeah
that's that's all it is and what happens
what does that look like is there like a
little man that walks around or is it
yeah it was a cube it was a red cube in
a field of bigger cubes the first big
game design problem is what do you do
you're in this four-dimensional world
great but like what does that even add
to your game well if you could move in
four dimensions what could you do
and what
the things is you have a wall you can
just go around it in the fourth
dimension and so to a three-dimensional
being it looks like you're disappearing
and appearing on the other side of the
wall but you've just went you just went
around it this is not the game yet well
it's almost the game but it just it's
missing a dimension so it's just sort of
an example of what the game would be
like if it was just a 3d game so we've
got your character and he's trying to
get on the other side of that wall but
you can't but it turns out that he is on
a two-dimensional plane within
three-dimensional world right there's
thickness to the world that he didn't
know about you can see that there there
would be a way to go around the wall
this way right but the guy is just 2d so
how'd you let him move in 3d while still
remaining on the two-dimensional plane
so he's like a thin pancake and he can't
yes and also he doesn't know about dis
direction so the mechanic of the game is
is you press a button and it rotates the
plane by 90 degrees so that now when
you're moving this way it doesn't mean
the same thing it means moving along the
third dimension so so now he can't walk
towards his girl right but he can walk
along the mysterious third dimension
that he didn't know about before and
when you press the button again it
always rotates around the character so
now he's back to his original facing
direction but he's further along that
way right so he can't see the wall you
can't see the wall like if I go back to
his perspective from within the plane
then you see like who is in this sort of
the desert place and then his rubble on
the ground but you can't see the wall
because it's along the third dimension
somewhere so now he can just walk
forward and you could see like he's
going past the wall and then turn back
again so now he's back to the sort of
sideways orientation where he can move
along the third dimension I move forward
and I turn again and now I'm on the
other side of the wall so I'm going to
go back
to the inside view and I see like okay I
went around the wall the thing is he's
only two dimensional so like that didn't
sort of shock him too much right it's
not like he suddenly could see the third
dimension he was just always moving in
ways that were two-dimensional right and
it's just the the fact that he can turn
which two-dimensional plane he's on that
let him move in three dimensions he's
like what you've done except up a gear
yes says mega Cray is the same idea you
can turn this plane that you're on into
a direction that you couldn't see at
first and that's how you navigate the
fourth dimension so same thing is you're
pressing a button and it rotates your
plane by 90 degrees so now you sort of
this perspective where you can move
between these parallel universes you can
move forward just like we did in the 2d
case and press the button again and now
you're further along the fourth
dimension whatever that means and
there's still rubble on the ground where
the wall was and I can walk past the
rubble but the thing is in the 2d / 3d
case I could move the camera out so that
you could see the perspective of three
dimensional being even though the
two-dimensional character was stuck in
this two-dimensional plane in in this
case we can't really do that right like
is the universe the real universe is
three dimensional so there's no way of
like seeing all of it seeing all of four
dimensions at once right so we're stuck
in sort of this plane view so now I
moved past the wall I press the button
again to get back to the perspective of
moving along the fourth dimension I go
back to the world that I started from
and rotate back but now when I'm on the
other side of the wall so how much time
has gone into it so far and five years -
yes
No five years yes well it's a hard game
to make there were a lot of challenges
to be figured out as I was making it can
I ask a silly question you don't wanna
talk about this if you don't want to but
how do you eat for five years when
you're making a game like this is like a
you've gone all-in here haven't you yeah
I mean I just had some money saved up I
guess
and um it was just me mostly just you
know so I figured out how to survive if
you're over here and you're trying to
get to that gate on top of the red block
but it's too high so you need something
to stand on maybe over here or over here
in order to be able to get to it you
need a big step yeah there's this
building but it's closed from all
directions so you're not going to be
able to go in easily but it turns out
it's not actually closed from the fourth
dimension so you can just just like in
the previous level you can just walk
around the wall and get inside the
building now I'm inside the building and
I see that there's this block nothing is
blocking this book to be moved in the
fourth dimension so what are you doing
in so I'm back to this sort of sideways
you I can push the block along the
fourth dimension and just to sort of see
what happened now it's gone from this
world it's gone from the inside of the
temple where is it well I moved to this
world where I can just push it forward
this is the same block but looking at it
with mention I'm moving it forward I can
move it back to the world that it
started in so now let's see what that
looks like from this perspective and now
I see that I move the block out of the
temple and push it forward and that's it
I mean that looks pretty coach may I
have far down the path I we're pretty
far along I mean there needs to be more
art more like you know content make the
game look better maybe fix some of the
lighting
things like that there's some still some
little design to do in sort of the
advanced sections but the the beginning
of the game is pretty solid people can
play foo for a few hours at what point
do you start worrying that someone's
going to pinch the idea well oddly I was
really worried about it like two or
three years ago but nothing really
happened and I think it's because it's a
really hard game to make and you don't
even know if it's going to be that
successful and if you're good I mean
that's my friend serious like if you're
really good enough to make that game
then you probably have your own ideas
and those are the ones that you want to
do you're always being asked about
release date what do you say I say when
it's done but we're definitely I feel
like we're downhill now we've figured
out the hard problems we're just making
it now we're just finishing it up but
that can still take a long time how
BIG's the code now how BIG's the monster
I do not count I'm sorry what is the
code oh it's citrus blush it's my own
engine you know nobody's done for tea in
that way before